the wind is very cold it is a dry wind
so you can feel electricity in the air
what does that do you can
shake your hand with someone you meet in
the street and you have electrical
um what you say yeah you get shocked
yeah so
it can surprise you
that's sabina viazzoli and she's from a
place that's famous for its win trieste
italy
how can you tell when someone is a
tourist oh if he or she has an umbrella
when we have bora and rain this is the
first
yes the first
way to recognize someone who is not from
trieste
it gets broken in few minutes
trieste is a medieval seaport town
located off italy's northeastern coast
but it is not your typical italian city
and one of the reasons is it just so
happens to sit directly in the path of
an intensely cold wind called the borah
the borah wind is in some way the
superstar in trieste
[Music]
and from ted this is far flaw
in each episode we visit a different
location to understand ideas that flow
from that place
and today we're talking to people
in places where the wind blows strongest
and strangest from trieste to the swiss
alps to northeastern spain
to explore how wind not only shapes the
physical environment around us
but also the lives of people who live in
its path
hi everybody
i am
i feel like teeny teeny nails are biting
my hands but i can manage i'm here
for you sabita offers tours through
trieste but it's not a typical tour you
are guaranteed to feel something on this
because it's a tour about the wind
sabina sees trieste like an open-air
museum for the borah
i thought that it would be
a very nice way to make people to know
my town
and so
i invented a sort of
working tour about the borah but even if
you visit trieste on a day when the
borah is not blowing you can see a lot
of strange clues as to how much the wind
shapes life there
you'll see how the trees only have
leaves on one side pointing in the
direction the wind travels and there's
stones resting on the rooftops to keep
roof tiles from blowing off
we can see some
very difficult threstine windows
they are very strange they look like
they are pushed out of the building
there are double
glasses
and
these are windows against bora
you have to imagine that when people
didn't have modern heating and they used
to
have fire in the kitchen in the house to
make the house warm and in a cold day of
winter and bora like this if you opened
the window the temperature will go
down very very soon
there are so many winds
in the world when people ask you what
makes the borough win special what do
you tell them
oh
i tell them that they have to
feel it
because
it's a very strong experience
i love bora but after three days of
borah i say okay thank you you can go
away
please
it's enough
so it depends on how long it lasts
the borah affects people in trieste in
all sorts of ways
you even have to plan everyday
activities around the wind stuff like
hanging your laundry
you can also see
a lot of strange things like laundry
hanging on the branch trees or
on the lamp on in the street because if
you hang your laundry out of the window
maybe you can lose your socks or your
t-shirt and who knows where
they go
so if you're visiting trieste you gotta
literally hold on to your hat as well as
anything else that might fly off you
but if you can't go on sabine's wind
tour you can catch a glimpse of how
locals live with and see the borah in a
film shot in the 1950s in trieste called
the boro wind
[Music]
fiend
you see the wind just wreaking havoc on
the city like this playful invisible
godzilla
imagine old ladies being escorted across
public squares by police bed protecting
them with their bodies as if they're in
a war zone
and pedestrians literally pulling
themselves along using ropes strung
along the sidewalk like they're climbing
a steep
[Applause]
and even though the borah sounds a bit
dramatic and scary
people from trieste have said that part
of why they gracefully welcomed the
borah
is that they
think of it as a symbol of strength and
heartiness by enduring the borah
throughout time it's like a symbolic
reminder they can get through anything
all the big uncomfortable things life
throws at you that you can't predict or
control
and we talked to a bed who's devoted a
huge part of his life to celebrating the
borah's two-sided nature
elventospira espira the wind blows and
gives inspiration the wind has no
borders this is very important because
we live on the same planet we have to
work together we are all in the same
home
that's reno lombardi founder of the
museo la bora tries very own wind museum
which he admits is as absurd as it
sounds it's a crazy idea to operate a
wind museum
benvenuti questa au de aguida viacom
is
today interested the wind is very strong
it's clear to watch this on the sea
because in the sea you can watch
a special effect that is called like a
smoke effect the sea become white the
waves are not so high because the wind
arrives from the land here and jump into
the sea
you can see the effects of the borah
outside of course
but how do you create an indoor museum
about something that's only visible
outdoors
for reno the winds invisibility and
existence outside of the realities we
construct well
that's the point
for me is important for a metaphoric
sense a borah for example is a wind that
has no borders is important because this
wind takes together all the different
solo town with the rest of the world
trieste was originally one of the major
seaports of the austro-hungarian empire
a vital mediterranean strategic location
but when italy became independent
trieste kind of lost its relevance italy
has plenty of coastline so it didn't
need trieste in the same way but when
the borah blows reno says it brings the
town vitality and purpose
the wood gives the city a sense of
excitement danger and drama that it used
to embody borah is a celebrity of the
town i'm not
full of courage but when there is bora i
can walk in the tank it's like to go
in a spa you catch this energy and then
you can do everything
even something as impossible sounding as
opening a wind museum everything you
find on display there relates to the
wind there's those ropes from the film
recorded and written memories of the
wind books films photographs of the
aftermath of a strong gust of wind
newspaper clippings scientific
instruments used by wind scholars
and on display you can also find objects
that you wouldn't necessarily expect to
see
like an iron
when reno opened the museum an elderly
woman from trieste wrote reno to tell
him that her mom
used to put an iron in her school bag so
that she wouldn't fly away with the wind
blew on her walk to school yes in the
days with bora there is this presence of
the wind of the nature in the town so we
find in the town images that are more
similar to fantasy than to reality
because we watch things flying leaves
turning like small tornadoes things can
morph and change quickly so
folks just have to adapt the uncertainty
of not knowing how long or intensely the
borah will blow
gusts have been recorded as strongly as
180 kilometers per hour that's more than
110 miles per hour and can last for days
at a time
bridges get shut down traffic jams start
vendors have to shut down their shops so
wind is something that like a lot of
things in our life could be bad or be
good but we try to watch the positive
part of the wind the bora is wind who
loves sense of your moon
many locals told us they have a
love-hate relationship with the borah in
trieste there's two names for two faces
of the borah light borah where it leads
to a bright sunny day and dark bora when
it brings dark clouds and bone chilling
gusts reno says he wants people to come
to his museum to appreciate the wind's
two-sided nature for me he's an
invitation to curiosity and that
curiosity about wins led to someone
setting out on foot and following them
i love this idea of following something
that you couldn't see something that
doesn't really exist but affects people
all the time and they just don't talk
about it or think about it that's nick
hunt he wrote a book called where the
wild winds are which tracks his journey
following four of europe's legendary
winds so it really came from seeing a
map i'll show you actually nick opened
his book and showed me this large map
with arrows on it pointing in all
directions the arrows mark weather
patterns where the wind blows
and they cross all recognizable borders
countries continents mountains and
oceans
and where i just see weather arrows
nick saw a journey it was very exciting
learning these wins had names and faces
and personalities it made them seem like
people that i could meet they all sound
like kind of invitations to a quest you
know i've been thinking a bit about the
story of these two fish who meet and one
of them asks the other how's the water
and the second fish says what's water
and i was thinking about how for us you
know that metaphor is used to explain
many things that we are surrounded by
but don't understand but for us the air
is of course the analog to the water we
never think about it except when it
moves and that's wind and i was curious
how you started thinking about it
you know once you become interested in
something you start seeing it everywhere
whereas before i'd be walking down the
street kind of oblivious to what was
going on in the atmosphere around me
suddenly clouds would be signals they'd
give me clues what was happening and i
just become more sensitive to the
fluctuations of these currents that blow
over our skin and through our hair all
the time and affect so many of the
things we see and to understand which
wind he was feeling nick needed some
tools that he could rely on
he had the basics a compass and an
anemometer a gadget you hold up to the
wind to measure its speed and also one
more super lightweight somewhat
unconventional tool
one of the most useful tools you can
have is just a little bit of wool just
to kind of hold up and see which way the
wind's blowing it's like having a wind
sock because a lot of the winds that i
was expecting to find were very
directional you can really tell what
kind of wind it is by what direction
it's coming from
out of all the winds nick met in person
there was one that affected him most
intensely the infamous phone win in the
swiss alps
and like the borah the phone has a split
personality it's associated with the
coming of spring the flowers coming out
on the alpine meadows and this sort of
picture perfect blue sky a very clear
light but it's also associated with
profoundly negative feelings and with
destruction and fire i lost count of the
number of alpine towns that somewhere
would have a plaque about the great fern
fire where the town apparently burned to
the ground
i don't think i talked to anyone who if
they weren't personally affected they'd
have a sister or an uncle who was
all of these stories made nick
increasingly excited to find the phone
but the phone is elusive and he was in
this remote mountain village
so getting around was not so easy
he had these graphs and charts with him
showing him it was supposed to be
blowing but it just didn't show up
i could feel the anticipation in the air
and people have written about this the
way that the coming of the fern sort of
enlivens the senses and everything
becomes a bit manic the next morning he
woke up to the sound of a furious roar
and i looked outside everything was
moving the trees were whipping back and
forth and there were hats flying off
people's heads everything was disturbed
and rubbish was flying through the air
there was dust and it was just this kind
of furious energy and my walk that day
took me along the shores of this lake it
looked like the wind was writing on its
surface it's kind of calligraphic swirls
and loops cat's paws they call it these
kind of fan shapes of the wind moving
across water and people were just
standing at the lake and staring you
know it felt like families had kind of
come out to see this spectacular event
did you ever experience the flip side of
that wind yes that was the happy
encounter i saw the fern at its kind of
playful energy and the second time it
was deeper in the mountains in this
spectacularly beautiful valley with
waterfalls crashing down it as he was
walking through these pine forests he
felt something change and suddenly i was
feeling this warm air blowing in my face
and then very quickly it just
intensified i remember the air feeling
quite fit like i was wading through
liquid
unlike the other winds that came in
bursts or gusts nick said that the phone
he found in the alps was like an open
hose pipe it was non-stop one of the
first things that was unsettling is
feeling a hot wind blowing from what you
can see are snow-capped mountains it
just feels wrong so it's just got this
uncanny sense and then waterfalls being
blown upwards which was also wonderful
to see but wrong as well it just felt
like that's not right
like a movie where the sound doesn't
match the picture
he had found the phone but instead of
turning back he wanted more so he set up
his tent to ride out the night
i spent the night thinking my tent was
gonna fall down but it felt like it was
being kicked on all sides and i woke up
in the morning and it the wind was still
blowing but i just remember thinking
okay that's enough i've got what i'm
looking for but it didn't stop and over
the course of that day i just
experienced this kind of sudden
profound plunge into deep depression via
anxiety
sort of bordering on paranoia i just
felt awful it was just like going down
this kind of spiral my whole reason for
being there felt ridiculous you know
this book i was trying to write felt
like a waste of time
nick's whole body felt so weak he says
he could barely stand up
he just wanted to stay curled up in his
tent
i saw an old sign somewhere saying that
if someone is suffering from fern crank
height you should remove them from the
valley that they're in and take them to
the next valley where the wind isn't
blowing and they'll quickly recover
the locals have a name for this
phone cronkite or phone sickness
so to get out of the phone's path he
crawled down the mountain and caught a
train to the next town
and i felt absolutely fine the next day
and it was only then that i thought ah
okay that was the wind that's what
everybody has told me happens
insomnia anxiety depression exhaustion
it just felt like oh my life's terrible
that's all i could think
for a traveler it's a thing to be
avoided but for folks who live in the
paths of these winds you can't just
leave town whenever the wind picks up
it's something we kept bumping into when
talking to folks
the wind offers a choice to follow the
instinctual fight or flight
or to surrender
and some say that if you stay strange
things might happen like maybe a flash
of madness or spark of passion or
creativity
after the break
[Music]
because if you're
living in a house and you have three
months of at least 100 kilometers an
hour wind going up and down well
shall we say it produces a certain level
of madness you lose yourself in what is
a totally natural environment but it
seems unreal it seems almost impossible
it can look quite like that
that's chris little talking about the
thrombontana it's a wind that is famous
for making the sky this intensely
brilliant blue color when it blows
spanish filmmaker cesar pescera who
co-produced this episode with us
even made a film about it it takes place
in carlequez a kind of postcard perfect
fishing village in the north of spain
that's known for attracting famous
artists like salvador dali who lived and
painted there for a lot of his life
i think many people probably think that
dali was a great genius and then they
come here and they go
well actually
quite a lot of it is because they could
already see it
to look into this connection between the
winds madness and creativity cesar
introduced me to dr antonio bobena a
psychiatrist from catalonia spain he has
a clinical practice and actually treats
local patients for wind-related
disorders
luckily for dr bulbana he says the wind
brings out his own cuddly side and well
what better when you are in bed looking
at the moon with traumatic holding and
you are just making a good hope with
your wife this is really the best thing
some people prefer fire but when you
feel more close to the other people
but for people who are especially
sensitive to the weather
dr balbana believes the wind is not just
an annoyance but that it can actually
affect them both physically and
psychologically you are going to be
anxious you are going to have headaches
you are going to feel uncomfortable
i think that the women quite like the
imagination will take you towards the
dark side echoes of dali's melted clocks
the wind is something that tells you
that you are not in control something
wrong might happen and then there is the
sound and in fact in a lot of terror
films they use this sound you put the
howl and then everybody gets prepared to
jump
imagine it's a gloomy evening you're
home alone a strong wind picks up you
hear the creaking of the walls the
scratch of a branch against your window
this howling wind
and then from behind you you hear
so it's not just the physical effect but
also the audio effect of wind it scares
you this might be very deep in our brain
the main abilities of our mind is
prediction this kind of prediction is a
very important thing in animals in fact
a lot of fishermen they take a dog in
their ships in order to have the
prediction of the weather the thing is
that you have to learn how to understand
what dog is going to tell you
so as humans we pay attention to the
weather in order to predict a possible
threat well we are just natural beings
we are quite away from what animals are
prepared to survive in the nature and
therefore we are really in a very
different situation but sometimes this
is not very comfortable it is a beauty
to have this sign that tells you that
you are still part of the nature not
just a robot in your house
the wind has so many sides to it it can
be playful destructive terrifying but no
matter where it blows across continents
and cultures it reminds us that
everything is interconnected and that
takes us back to the borah museum
that's where reno makes a peculiar
request he asks people from all over the
world to send him
winds such as the phone or tromantana
that they capture in whatever container
they can find jars bottles cups cans
tins boxes envelopes you name it there's
probably a wind in it on display in his
museum and everyone has an idea that is
different we receive a box of a girl
said a small wind is written the wind
desired to come in this box the wind was
not captured what was something
spontaneous of doing
rito claims he's received over 200 wins
some folks go all out and write detailed
labels for their wind with the wind name
location speed direction and day
his most prized wind a sneeze in a batch
box straight from the nose of the french
illustrator olivier duzuk
so how do you capture the wind everyone
has a system you can catch the wind in a
different way for example you can make
like a trap you know you do with the
mouse you put the cheese you put a liver
i put a leaf in a trap yes and then the
wind will come to that leaf and i can
capture the wind that way i love it
and to encourage folks to send him all
these wits rito offers something in
return here's nick if you send him one
of these wins he sends you a certificate
in the post the very official
certificate says that you're an honorary
wind ambassador to the borah museum
which win did you send him i actually i
i still owe him a helm
the helm is a win that blows in england
where nick is from
and i gotta interrupt to say this is my
favorite debt i have ever heard of
honestly i have thought i'll just send
him an empty jar and just make a nice
label but i can't bring myself to do
that i mean i feel like he might know if
i cheated i love what this says about
you that you feel like you want to set
up the real wind i could not help but
mention this dorito
nick owes you some wind he says he's
going to send you a jar with some wind
that he hasn't sent you yet yes i am i'm
waiting so better relation with the nick
no no i'm joking
he thought you know maybe i should just
send a jar of air he had been tempted to
deceive you but that he wasn't gonna
deceive you he was gonna get you the
real wind tell me what it means to you
that people are getting you the real
wind when they could just send you a jar
from anywhere you know it's a moment of
generosity so i'm happy when i watch in
the post say ah today there is a box or
maybe they call me from the post office
i go to take a packet and they say what
is there is a an empty bottle no
it's not an empty bottle this is a full
of wind so there are two kind of
thinking life you can think that is like
the glass empty or full i say it's full
of wind so it's different it's another
kind of thinking to life i try to be
positive optimistic way this has been a
joy to talk to you one vein
[Music]
rito kept reminding us that the
absurdities of the wind are a great
reminder not to take ourselves too
seriously
and so on an unusually windy day back
home in north carolina
i decided to claim a spot in trieste
bike check
here talking here for a sec hello
okay
hello
just talking a normal voice hello
that's me my kids back in january just
after we had gotten a bit of snow okay
so we are outside it is a post
snow
breeze
is there wind blowing now you guys um i
can feel a little a breeze
yeah me too do you guys know how to
capture wind
um do you just like put it in a box some
people put in an envelope some people
put in a jar how do you do that
what do you think we can use as bait for
the wind what do you think the wind
likes
i don't know
maybe um one of the
leaves on a small tree
okay well let's try and catch the wind
suit guys get the beat
okay i'll go grab it
okay so put in the box and guys watch
and see when you feel some wind and when
you think some might be in the box and i
guess just close it as fast as you can
okay okay
what's that
okay they're starting to be breezy
around here
oh yeah do you think it's time i think
it's time
okay
i think we caught it okay i'm gonna send
this to italy
okay see if it survives yeah we'll see
if it makes the trip
thanks guys
farflung is produced by jesse baker and
eric newsome of magnificent noise for
ted our local producers for this episode
are cesar pescera and mark sanchez
they're two short films about the winds
santa ana and tramantana inspired this
episode our production staff includes
elise blenrahase huete getana sabrina
farhi michelle quint jimmy gutierrez bam
ben chang and sammy case and with the
guidance of roxanne highlash and colin
helms our fact checkers are nicole bodie
and christian apartheim ad stories
produced by transmitter media this
episode was mixed and sound designed by
elise blennerhasset and paul schneider
additional music by cesar pescera
stainless steel sound chris zabriskie
and lemon gua
additional thank you to trumantana's
film art director christian lopez and
writer caco mendez and to everyone we
spoke with for this episode nick hunt
sabina villasoli rino lombardi and dr
bulbana for your time and expertise
our executive producer is eric newsom
i'm celine rashemwalla
[Music]
you